Oh
well we always say the most important
things you can do about health and
wellness is to control the things you
can and get politically active around
the things you can't so when it comes to
food well you need a good food supply if
you can't get locally grown organic
foods and you get mostly what I call
crap available in your community to
purchase you've got to do something
about changing that if you do have
access to community supported
agriculture or access to organic food
and you can afford it support those
sources of good food the most important
thing is fresh fruits and vegetables
whole grains minimize the amount of
prepared and processed foods you take in
high fructose corn syrup which is really
an awful substances in almost everything
you buy and prepared commercially
prepared products we need to avoid high
fructose corn syrup as much as possible
we also need to try to avoid a certain
type soy isolate isolate it pro teens
and some will get into it right now but
many of the soy products contain this
substance we need to get fermented soy
products if we have soy but really turn
to a more varied diet not think about
the latest fad latest processed food as
a solution but more Whole Foods
minimally processed and they're easy to
cook they're quick to cook it's a myth
fit cooking is so labor-intensive there
are ways to learn how to cook that
network also what about the air we
breathe we may have to do something as a
community to do that whether we've got
an industry nearby polluting the air it
can vary from community to community
what about our water sources we
certainly don't want water privatized we
certainly want to make sure water is as
clean as it can be but we have to
understand that bottled water is not the
solution and there are good expose ace
of that all over the internet right now
and then finally we have to do something
about violence in women's lives that is
critically important to sustaining our
health and well-being well where do you
start you can start in one place
whatever appeals to you you can't do all
of these things at once certainly if you
join a group and support a group that's
doing something you care about you give
them your money
that's one way but giving your time your
expertise going to the local school to
speak about some of these issues those
are other ways that you can educate the
community and that you can go about
making this the health a priority in
terms of the environment so it's not
about new drugs it's not about bigger
medical centers it's about healthier
communities and we can all do something
in our own small way to make healthy
healthier communities a reality